this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by hover get 10% off your
next domain purchase using the code real
engineering in 2007 Steve Jobs
introduced the original iPhone one of
the most innovative and revolutionary
products of the 21st century assuring in
a new era of smart phones and waiting in
line to get one the furor over this new
phone was due in large part to the LCD
multi-touch panel and that allowed you
to see and interact with the device with
a clarity and mobility never seen before
Apple wasn't the first to introduce
touch panel LCDs into phones but they
were the first to make people care about
it
they revolutionized what was once a
clunky and frustrating technology - one
that could be easily used for typing on
screen and gesture control the screen
itself featured a 3.5 inch diagonal 320
by 480 resolution LCD major shifts and
iPhone usability and design over the
years have been around the display from
the iPhone to the iPhone 3GS the phones
had a display density of 163 pixels per
inch the iPhone 4 Retina display double
dot the 326 PPI this pixel size remained
constant for another seven years while
generational progress was made in LCD
technology more consistent backlighting
consistent color and brightness when
viewing off angle and a wider color
gamut gave the new iPhone 8 the gold
standard LCD panel but for the iPhone 10
Apple has taken a sudden departure from
its fateful LCD screens and jumping in
bed with her archrival Samsung
who are manufacturing its new OLED
display the Apple watch used OLED but
Samsung has been utilizing a maturing
OLED technology for years in their
Galaxy smartphones this is the first
time most Apple enthusiasts will
experience OLED technology so what are
the fundamental differences between LCD
and OLED lcd stands for a liquid crystal
display the liquid crystals used falls
somewhere between a liquid and a solid
which allows them to change their
molecular orientation when an electrical
current is applied this is incredibly
useful as it allows us to use the
molecules to manipulate light that is
passing through the liquid crystal
liquid crystal pixels do not produce
their own light but in modern LCD panels
LED backlighting is used with a
backlight uniformity filter added to
ensure even lighting across the panel
next the light passes through a
polarization film which only lets light
traveling in the horizontal orientation
to pass
through followed by the liquid crystal
group and then another polarizing filter
orientated 90 degrees to the first if
you're familiar with polarizing filters
you will know that light cannot pass
through two filters when they're aligned
perpendicular to each other so light
depends on this liquid crystal layer to
orientate the light to allow to pass
through the second filter the liquid
crystal layer is sandwiched between two
electrodes and two pieces of H glass
forcing the liquid crystal molecules
into a near predictable 90 degree twist
when a voltage is applied through the
electrodes the crystal molecules begin
to realign in the direction of the
current a larger voltage will result in
a full 90 degree twist as light passes
through it will follow the direction of
the crystal molecules before
encountering the second polarization
filter so the liquid crystal layer
essentially acts as a controllable light
valve if light is allowed to pass it
will travel through a colored filter
giving it one of three colors red blue
or green this structure is called a
sub-pixel
combine three subpixels with red green
and blue filters and you have a single
traditional RGB liquid crystal pixel
this brings up a few really interesting
characteristics of LCDs the first is
that even when the panel is displaying a
black image the backlight is always on
causing a large battery drain and some
light leakage at pixel boundaries and at
the edges of the screen which negatively
affects the screen contrast ratio with
the iPhone X Apple engineers have
adopted a fundamentally new display
technology OLED or organic
light-emitting diodes Samsung have a
near perfect monopoly on the
manufacturing market for these screens
manufacturing 90% of the world's supply
and holding the majority of the world's
patents forcing competitors like Apple
to purchase from them to remain up to
date with the best technology on the
market although it hasn't stopped them
from reportedly investing billions in
Samsung's major competitor LG display
OLED works very differently from LCD in
a few key ways for starters there's no
backlight instead each pixel is
self-illuminating through the light
emitting process called electrophoresis
there are two organic compounds called
the emissive and conductive layers that
are sandwiched between an anode and a
cathode as an electrical current flows
from the cathode to the anode electrons
are given to the emissive layer and
removed from the conductive layer the
electrons in the emissive layer now
migrate to fill the holes in the
conductive layer
when they do extra energy is released as
a photon this entire process is
controlled and structured by the TFT
matrix and the entire structure is
placed on a substrate of either glass or
polymer since there is no backlight and
each individual pixel is individually
controlled substantial power saving can
occur when displaying dark or black
images in addition OLED panels are
significantly thinner and lighter than
their LCD counterparts allowing for
slimmer devices with razor-sharp bezels
and flexible screens like the one in the
Samsung Galaxy s8 lastly OLED panels of
high brightness and true zero pixel
values leading to insane contrast ratios
of over 1 million to one
blacks are inky colors are more vibrant
and localized brightness can be greatly
improved there are some growing pains
with OLED technology holding it back in
the mainstream consumer market
the chief limiting factor is burnin
burnin occurs when the organic layers of
the pixel begin to break down from
prolonged usage as the layers decay they
become significantly less bright than
the pixels around them which can make
stationary UI elements appear as ghost
images this mainly occurs from prolonged
static images such as user interface
icons and as the single largest reason
oled computer monitors or TVs are not
yet mainstream not to mention the cost
which can be 1.5 to 2 times higher than
an equivalent LCD panel Oh lad has
fundamental strengths over LCD that will
open up possibilities for how and where
displays are used in the world around us
LG Display has a consumer OLED
television that is only 2.5 7
millimeters thick they are working on
transparent ohlet's that can be
integrated into glass panels and various
OLED manufacturers are working towards
foldable displays with continued
improvement OLED displays look set to
revolutionize the way we consume and
view information in the world around us
websites on your phone will look better
than ever but what's a good website
without a great domain name hover is the
easiest and best place to register a
custom domain or email you can even
purchase domains right from your iPhone
using Apple pay they have over 400
domain extensions and the best customer
service in the business seriously
they've won awards I couldn't believe my
luck when I saw that the real
engineering domain was available on
hover and purchased it immediately and
it took less than 20 seconds to make it
mine I now have a custom email address
that couldn't suit my channel better if
you're looking for a unique domain name
hover
the best place to get one and you can
get 10% off your next purchase using the
code real engineering you could get the
real investments domain and use it for
your online investment training site or
you could get the real tough security
domain name for your cyber security
block whatever domain you want you will
probably be able to find one that suits
your needs at hover and once again you
can get ten percent off your next
purchase using the code real engineering
as always thanks for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters if
you'd like to see more from me the links
from my social media accounts are in the
description
[Music]
you